the Phoenix program was created by the
CIA and its purpose was to kill and
terrorize and Vietnam was forced to do
business with a police chief who was a
sadistic mutilator of prisoners he liked
to carve them up and throw the remains
in the river and he was completely paid
and popped up by the CIA his whole
career depended on one controlling that
operation so at the CIA needed him and
two of the cie propping him up and
funding him and he did his knife work in
a CIA safe house called it the pink
house I reported this to the chief of
station and he said well you know it's a
rough world and sometimes you have to do
business with people that really aren't
your first choice of the kind of people
you want to associate with so don't make
a way and so I went back you know what I
do resign my post yeah you know that's
obviously that's your last vote though
you resign and you're out and I wasn't
ready to give up my career yet I
terminated the safe house I told the
case officers that I don't want to hear
about it if this guy has a compulsion to
do this sort of thing anymore I don't
want to hear about it